bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors une possible
commission d' enquête parlementaire
voulue par les républicains est ce que
c'est une demande légitime selon vous
d'abord bonjour
écoutez oui nous considérons que c'est
une demande légitime comme est légitime
la demande de nombreux citoyens et des
collectifs de médecins dont vous avez
fait part dans notre reportage
chacun peut observer que la gestion du
gouvernement de cette crise
catastrophique est elle parfaitement
calamiteuse tant dans la manière de
s'adresser aux citoyens que dans le
maintien des élections municipales le
premier tour des élections municipales
que dans la manne la capacité à fournir
des masques et des tests qui sont
absolument absolument nécessaire donc à
un moment donné on ne gouverne pas
impunément et les responsabilités
doivent être doivent être désignés mais
je pense que ce sera quelque chose qui
se fera après la crise mais j'ai
l'impression que la grande partie des
citoyens n'accepterons pas que on balaye
la poussière sous le tapis
alors vous dites après la crise mais on
voit que les plaintes elles elles
s'accumulent contre le gouvernement même
si c'est vrai ce gouvernement met en
avant l'importance d'une solidarité
nationale d'une urgence nationale
est ce que vous pensez vous que c'est un
peu trop tôt quand même pour pointer les
responsabilités
non absolument pas nous l'avons fait
nous même très récemment
je veux dire la résolution de ces
plaintes
je vois mal comment elle pourrait se
tenir sachant que nous sommes tous
confinés c'est un petit peu
techniquement compliqué alors si le
gouvernement
effectivement parle de solidarité
nationale oui il doit y avoir une
solidarité nationale mais avec nos
soignants avec tout ce qu'ils font que
nous puissions nous alimenter c'est à
dire les les ceux qui travaillent dans
les supermarchés les les chauffeurs
routiers mais je ne suis pas certain
qu'il faille nécessairement avoir une
solidarité derrière ce gouvernement
et d'ailleurs pour la comparaison
puisque monsieur macron qui se prenait
pour jupiter
il se compare maintenant à clemenceau il
faut lui rappeler que clemenceau entre
1914 et 1917 durant la première guerre
mondiale n'hésitait pas à critiquer les
erreurs du gouvernement qui justement ne
permettait pas là la victoire
or la critique est légitime nous sommes
en démocratie et ce gouvernement a
montré bien et fire s'agissant des
enquêtes parlementaires un qui sera
possible donc à la demande des
républicains
qu'en attendez-vous concrètement parce
que il ya beaucoup d'affaires avec des
beaucoup d' enquête parlementaire que
l'on a suivi et au final c'est difficile
d'en voir le bout ce qui aura des
résultats vous pensez écoutez
personnellement je n'attends pas grand
chose de l' enquête parlementaire en
elle même l'assemblée nationale est à
majorité république en marche
et comme vous savez la grande enquête
parlementaire qui a eu lieu suite à la
sphère bénin la mennais la macro qui n'a
toujours pas été réglée faut-il le
rappeler a été retiré par l'assemblée
nationale par contre ce à quoi je crois
c'est à une prise de conscience des
citoyens et la crise montre bien que
montrent les erreurs de ce gouvernement
et montre que ces erreurs sont de plus
en plus comprise par les citoyens oui il
est absurde d'avoir un système à flux
tendu avec des gouvernements qui ont un
tableau excel dans la tête et qui
récitent des mantras néolibéraux oui il
est absurde d'avoir toute notre
industrie délocaliser et d'avoir aucune
capacité stratégique dans bien des
domaines dont celui de la santé et des
médicaments
oui il est absurde de résister pendant
un an à une grève des hôpitaux de
l'ensemble des hôpitaux en particulier
des services d'urgence qui pendant plus
d'un an avant la crise on précisé au
gouvernement qu'il manquait de moyens
que ça n'allait pas que les que les
soignants est en souffrance
avant la crise
donc il n'est pas étonnant qu'il ait ce
ras-le-bol du côté des soignants est
tous allés l'histoire et le voit or je
crois énormément à la mobilisation
citoyenne
donc là une éventuelle enquête
parlementaire peut être un appui mais ce
qui est important c'est la mobilisation
citoyenne la prise de conscience et de
mettre fin avec des politiques qui
nuisent à l'intérêt de la nation et des
français merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui kossmann évident je rappelle
que vous êtes président de république
souveraine merci à vous